tifu has announced his retirement from
streaming and content creation everyone
from around the community gave their
props but it got us wondering just how
good was tifu really he obviously had
great mechanical skill which he showed
off early in his career in games like
Destiny and H1Z1 but tfu's real big
break came with fortnite and you can say
he was pretty filthy above you
got him got him got him got him nice
nice
in addition to being a content creator
tifu was also nosed to the grindstone in
competing in fortnite Esports having
respectable finishes and some insane
highlights spraying out the
house
tifu then also made mainstream headlines
when he sued his former org FaZe Clan
the lawsuit eventually went away and
he's basically just been a content
creator ever since obviously still
killing it in pretty much every game he
touches or Zone Apex even Minecraft but
now tifu is taking an indefinite break
truly the end of an era